bonsoir et bienvenue dans ça vous
regarde ravi de vous retrouver ça y est
les jeux sont faits la campagne de
premier tour s'arrête ce soir à minuit
une campagne à nul autre pareil on l'a
vite étrange empêché certains ont parlé
d'une campagne tefal ou rien n'accroche
d'autres l'ont même trouvée passionnante
alors qu'il a réussi qu'il a raté cette
campagne on va dresser le bilan candidat
par candidat avec 4 fines lames de
journalisme politique dans un instant
sur ce plateau on reviendra aussi sur la
guerre en ukraine avec cette question
les européens ont-ils encore trop peur
de vladimir poutine le nouveau paquet de
sanctions l'embargo sur le charbon russe
est pour beaucoup en deçà de ce qu'il
faudrait faire côté livraisons d'armes
en revanche un cap a été franchi à
l'otan avec l'acheminement d'armes
lourdes aux ukrainiens à la veille d'une
bataille qui s'annonce très violente
dans le donbass on fera le tour de tous
ces sujets avec notre grand témoin le
géopolitologue dominique moïsi voilà
pour le menu ce soir c'est parti
[Musique]
et
bienvenue à vous chers téléspectateurs à
minuit tout sera fini c'est donc l'heure
de faire le bilan de cette drôle de
campagne avec quatre journalistes que
j'espère en pleine forme quatre
signatures s'il vous plaît yves thréard
bonsoir éditorialiste politique au
figaro carole barjon bonsoir
éditorialiste politique à l'ops
christophe barbier bienvenue sur ce
plateau éditorialistes est directeur de
la rédaction de francs tireurs et
catherine tricot bienvenue sur ce
plateau directrice des éditions de la
revue regards quelle drôle de campagne
dans un instant vous allez me donner
votre sentiment un mot peut être pour la
qualifier mais d'abord stéphane
blakowski bonsoir loïc dobler soir on
retrouve d'ailleurs ils ont vécu même
ses candidats comment tiens vous l'avez
vécu pour tendance alors moi je vous
dire cette campagne elle était décevante
elle était ratée mais en même temps elle
était utile et même parfois
enthousiasmante alors si je me permets
d'être un peu catégorique de tels délits
torriani story je vois déjà le tabac y
en a une qui n'est pas d'accord ce sont
les français qu'ils disent regardez bien
les français trouvent que la campagne
est décevante à 70% pour s inquiéter de
ça mais ce qui compte la psyché de
comparer avec les chiffres en bleu qui
sont les mêmes questions posées en 2017
vous voyez que il la trouve moins
décevante en 2010 est moins raté qu'en
2010 est plus utile qu'en 2017 et même
plus enthousiasmante alors pourquoi on
nous embête avec ces histoires de
campagne ratée ce qu'elle était un peu
particulière reconnaissaient leur est
d'accord je sais bien que j'en ai ils
seront peut-être déçus connaît le
résultat depuis le départ c'est l'ordre
une course qu'ils attendent depuis cinq
ans et là on leur gâche la fête bon ok
en même temps élevé comme des petites
j'excuse de président pour ne pas
participer pleinement à la fête il les a
donné ce matin sur rtl je pense qu'on
peut l'entendre
at on oublié qu'il y a deux mois on
vivait un pic épidémique dans nos
hôpitaux qu'il y à un mois et demi les
bombes commencé à tomber sur le créa
avec la guerre était déclenchée qui
aurait pu comprendre ya six semaines que
d'un seul coup j'allais faire des
rassemblements populaires commençaient à
faire de la politique domestique quand
la guerre était déclarée en ukraine le
contexte quand même le coc vis de la
guerre tout ça ça n'a pas faux c'est les
débats pas spécialement en tout cas pas
pour les candidats qui étaient bien
préparés mélenchon le pen voilà ça fait
cinq ans qu'ils se préparent ils sont
prêts quand la guerre en ukraine arrive
c'est vraiment pas quelque chose car âge
d'or qui arrangent leurs affaires mais
parce qu'ils sont bien lancés bien
préparé il arrive à surmonter cette
difficulté dans ce qui est en train de
swing en permanence sur la campagne qui
marche pas au rabais ceci c'est les
petits candidats qui sont toujours en
train de se plaindre de pas se faire
entendre et c'est vrai malgré tout pour
qu'on n'a pas plus entendu jean lassalle
est ce que cette campagne était à la
hauteur de son grand projet pour la
france je ne crois pas cette campagne
mais c'est une campagne de merde
vous comprenez mais on ne dit rien à
part des insultes des injures et puis
alors les ddd d'une vacuité est
saisissable
il aura peut-être parmi nous qui serons
d'accord vous pointez la vacuité
insaisissable de cette campagne mais bon
on peut aller plus loin encore faut
aussi se demander si tout ça ne fait pas
un peu truqués pas franchement du pt
nous on se pose la question le hic est
que je ne serai pas qu'il ya un scrutin
des lettres de a à z par des médias
complaisants de monsieur macro est une
oligarchie que vous représentez je vous
dis que les trucs qu'ils naissent que
vous faites dire je le dis ce que je
vaux populisme ce que vous représentez
une casse c'est du pays vous oubliez les
condos des français
les résultats d'une élection qui n'a pas
encore eu lieu ouais c'est vrai alors on
pensait en plus du contenu on n'est pas
très surprise qui voulait gouverner avec
florian philippot et le professeur raoul
donc le fait qu'ils soient sensibles
vérité alternative comme dit donald
trump on peut le comprendre en tout cas
on n'est pas surpris ce qui est plus
surprenant c'est que
valérie pécresse elle aussi se rallie au
point de vue de trump soleil trompeur
quand il a perdu ma il accuse hebeisen
de leur a volé l'élection et la barre
valérie elle porte les mêmes accusations
donald trump et il faut quand même se
souvenir de 2017 et cette élection elle
a été volée à la droite et c'est ça la
vérité et moi si je suis là ce soir
c'est parce que j'ai l'impression qu'on
est en train de refaire le scénario 2017
j'ai l'impression qu'on est en train
d'essayer de voler cette élection j'ai
l'impression qu'ils emmanuel macron est
en train de se dérober à cette élection
la question c'est est-ce qu'elle parlera
encore de vol si elle est pas qualifié
ce qu'il dira commissariat déposer
plainte dimanche soir pour vol
d'élections je ne sais pas ce qu'elle va
faire elle a dit sur france inter qu' à
titre personnel elle dirait pour qui
voterez mais qu'elle ne donnerait pas de
consignes donc on la sent quand même un
peu plus frileuses sur le côté remparts
républicains puisque je vous rappelle
qu'en 2007 elle avait clairement dit ah
oui même si c'est à contrecoeur il faut
voter macombe nous devons faire barrage
à marine le pen a manifestement sait pas
exactement la même chose qu'elle dira
dimanche soir donc voyez donc disais
depuis le début cette élection et jouer
puis finalement pas tant que ça du
suspens jusqu'aux mal voir alors comment
vous l'avez senti comprise un mot c'est
le petit jeu du premier tour de table
pour qualifier cette campagne extraits
comment je la qualifierais je dirais que
c'est une campagne crispée crispé parce
qu'il ya pas eu beaucoup de sourires
tendus
avec toujours l'oeil dans le rétroviseur
une espèce d'angoissé de l'avenir et
avec très peu de belles formules de
beaux discours
de deux ans finalement d'un verbe qui
vous transporte ce qu'on demande à une
présidentielle c'est une pièce de
théâtre une présidentielle hélas la
pièce de théâtre on peut dire qu'elle
était d'un niveau assez médiocre crispe
et endure
recroqueviller sur le passé vous l'avez
senti comme ça aussi moi j'ai trouvé
cette campagne paradoxal et inattendue
pourquoi parce que d'habitude les
campagnes ça démarre toujours un peu mou
et puis ça s'anime vers la fin et c'est
là en fait c'est exactement le contraire
à quoi on a assisté c'est à dire que
c'est à l'automne que beaucoup de choses
se sont passées parce que la percée
fulgurante d'eric zemmour à l'automne ça
n'est quand même pas une petite chose
dans cette campagne et même s'il a
aujourd'hui beaucoup baissé on voit
qu'il a encore un score plus que
convenable non mais je développe pas là
dessus tout ça pour dire que bon ce sont
passés en réalité à l'automne et la
percée des mots il ya eu la primaire
delà de la droite et là il ya eu
vraiment beaucoup de débats donc moi je
ne comprends pas très bien tous les gens
qui disent qu a pas eu de débat c'est
pas vrai il y en a eu il y en a eu
beaucoup et c'est vrai que bizarrement
en janvier tout s'est un peu comment
dire endormi et que là c'est vraiment la
dernière ligne droite où on voit que ça
se réanime mais ça s'est passé à
l'envers de la manière dont les choses
se passent d'habitude et par ailleurs je
la trouve historiquement intéressante à
bien vous nous direz pourquoi christophe
barbier crispé paradoxal et vous moi je
dirais que c'est une campagne
troglodytes arrivée du nom de ces
habitations creusées dans la pierre ou
sous le sol l'espace public était envahi
par l'aco vider la grève et la guerre
donc deux angoisses supérieur est
néanmoins cette campagne réussie à a de
manière souterraine a creusé son espace
et peut-être à saper un peu le paysage
politique actuel et peut-être même la la
république actuel donc il s'est passé
des choses en effet la percée des moore
qui a creusé sa galerie comme ça sur
certains thèmes qui maintenant sont un
peu plus escamoté marine le pen qui n'a
pas bougé accroché à sa nouvelle
personnalité et puis à ce thème du
pouvoir d'achat ça marchait pas elle se
faisait rodez tout doucement par zemmour
et puis à la fin ça paye et puis
emmanuel macron qui a fait une ou non
campagne plutôt réussi pendant plusieurs
mois et puis une campagne complètement
raté pendant quinze jours et donc voilà
tout était un peu à l'envers que c'était
un peu en souterrain en souterrain ce
qui est intéressant c'est que pour
l'instant personne ne dit qu'elle n'a
pas existé cette campagne évocatrice eu
d'accord qu'elle était en sous terrain
qu'elle a été beaucoup menées sur des
réseaux sociaux c'est dire qu'à défaut
de rencontre et de débat public sur les
grands médias c'est finalement la
confrontation à l'intérieur des réseaux
sociaux qui a fonctionné
quant aux grands candidats enfin aux
candidats d'une façon générale ils ont
chacun tracer leurs lignes dans leur
couloir de nage puisqu'il n'y avait pas
de rencontres possibles mais au total
beaucoup de sujets ont été abordés je
trouve que la place de la france l'idée
que l'on se fait de la france a été la
première partie et puis on atterrit à la
fin sur un débat une discussion sur le
social comme finalement moi je ne me
souviens pas en avoir jamais connu dans
une élection présidentielle voilà bien
bruce a beaucoup voilà deux
d'idées reçues finalement je vous
entends à contre-courant ça fait du bien
et ça réveille alors mélenchon 10 et lui
la carène la crise d'oka vide c'est
aussi des choses qui ont nourri le débat
qui se félicitait que par exemple la
grâce du coc vide et permis de faire un
vrai débat de fond sur l'hôpital alors
qu'il n'avait jamais réussi vraiment à
intéresser l'opinion les médias sous le
thème la france quand même que ça fait
très longtemps qu'on n'a pas vu autant
d'indécis et surtout
d'abstentionnistes on pourrait avoir un
record celui de 2002 tous les sondeurs
disent à peu près 30% dimanche soir ce
qui est déjà énorme ça veut dire quoi
c'est cesser cette campagne là qui n'est
pas mort à vous entendre c'est fait une
lame qu'il n'y a pas qu'une explication
il ya plusieurs nécessairement plusieurs
explications moi j'en vois j'en vois
deux principalement la première c'est
que cette campagne n'a pas réussi à
accrocher et ça veut pas dire que cette
abstention si elle a lieu d'ailleurs
c'est pas du tout sûr qu'on ait une
abstention telle qu elle a été décrite
par les les sondeurs rétention real
reçoit pas du tout au tout si on est à
25 % après tout ça sera pas une
catastrophe non plus donc c'est
certaines un certain désintérêt pour le
débat tel qu'il a existé mais ça veut
pas dire que c'est eu d'abstention qui
qui annonce une catastrophe moi je
rappelle je l' ai rappelé ce matin
derrière le journal en 2002 il ya une
forte abstention et en 2007 il ya eu un
engouement terrible parce qu'il y avait
une bonne pièce de théâtre mais c'est
quand même une campagne on entendu ce
mot de fatigue démocratique on sent que
dans la champions il ya aussi la notion
relative aux aguets mais c'est pas oui
mais ça faut arrêter parce qu'on répète
tout le temps ça il ya peut-être cette
fatigue démocratique il ya peut-être
aussi un phénomène générationnel c'est à
dire que chez beaucoup de jeunes et on
voit les jeunes quelle que soit
l'élection ces cartes maintenant des
urnes et peut-être que c'est pas une
forme d'expression qu'ils aient qu'ils
apprécient qu'ils approuvent qui leur
correspond une espèce d'individualisme
chez les jeunes qui fait qu' ils sont
loin peut-être d'un projet collectif
même les causes vont devoir de voter
directement ses terres que les modalités
du scrutin sont à repenser les rites de
la démocratie représentative sont à
repenser on l'avait vu au moment de la
crise des gilet jaune on le voit encore
maintenant on n'a pas la boîte outil qui
convient aux électeurs qui ont sans
doute encore des aspirations collectives
mais qui trouvent plus le qui trouve
plus le chemin il y aura deux
abstentions possible dimanche une
abstention sociologique on sait que ça
touche les couches populaires et donc ça
c'est plutôt mauvais pour mélenchon et
le pen ou bien une instance une
abstention politique comme celle qui
avait précipité la chute de lionel
jospin en 2002 puisque c'était pas
vraiment le pen qui était passé devant
mais plutôt jospin qui était passé
derrière
par pays et par qui exactement c'est
très politique oui je pense qu'un aussi
de la satisfaction malgré ce qu'on a dit
tout à l'heure on a trouvé de l'intérêt
mais tout le monde n'y a pas trouvé son
intérêt dans cette campagne serre en
particulier les jeunes je pense qu'on
souffre que la question écologique et
été si peu présente et je pense qu'ils
ont raison
par ailleurs par exemple dès que les
quartiers populaires ont été totalement
absents on n'a absolument pas parler de
la banlieue on à stigmatiser les
immigrés mais on n'a pas parlé de la
question des banlieues et des quartiers
populaires donc des raisons des absences
de cristallisation sur des sujets pour
des des générations ou des catégories
d'habitants qui n'ont pas peut-être
trouvé leur compte et d'ailleurs les
sondeurs nous disent que beaucoup
d'électeurs trouve que le discours était
un peu répétitif qui avait pas d'idées
nouvelles ça fait partie du problème à
mon avis carole un petit mot là dessus
on passe sur m'accroche et je suis assez
d'accord parce que il y avait une chose
est fait un papier là dessus dans l'ope
ce
dont on avait énormément parlé pendant
la crise des filets jaunes c'est la
fracture numérique est ce qu'on appelle
un peu les les les oubliés alors et les
invisibles et c est la fracture
numérique c'était un vrai gros sujet
alors fabien roussel a parlé on a parlé
un peu en disant qu'il fallait arrêter
la dématérialisation à marche forcée des
services de l'état parce que 20% de la
population est complètement perdu et
donc se sent abandonné donc je pense que
ça ça n'a fait papa ça n'a pas fait
partie des sujets qui auraient pu être
mis sur la table et puis par ailleurs ya
peut-être effectivement l'offre
politique qui est un peu décevante alors
on évacue candidats qui sont les mêmes
les mêmes termes la dernière fois aux
candidats enfin emmanuel macron on a
décidé de se baser sur le dernier
rolling de de ipsos pour france info le
parisien la courbe au fond depuis un
mois on la voit en jaune là où elle est
très claire elle fait ça et c'est vrai
que bon il ya un mois c'est laid c'est
le début de la guerre il ya 30%
aujourd'hui
26,5 qu'est ce qu'il a au fond ratés
dans cette campagne je pense qu'il
ratait deux choses d'abord sa présence
visible comme candidat puisque à peu
près au moment où il a commencé il y
avait des temps de parole dans les
médias qui ont fait que c'était plus
difficile pour lui d'être visible et
comme il a décidé de faire une campagne
en solitaire sans lancer ses armées sur
le champ de bataille il s'est lui-même
un visibiliser deuxième chose qui l'a
raté c'est une erreur pourtant sur
laquelle il avait été totalement prévenu
c'est que on ne n'ai jamais élu sur un
bilan donc il faut un projet dans ce
projet faut faire rêver faut avoir une
vision à long terme faut dessiner un
projet france faut essayer d'y mettre un
peu de positif parce que la retraite à
65 ans et le rsa sous conditions c'est
un peu punitif et ça ils là il n'a pas
compris il a pensé que dire j'ai fait
baisser le chômage j'ai fait quand même
pas mal de réformes et puis je vous ai
sorti d'épidémie ça allait suffire mais
non merci
on mettait des propositions sur
les rocades où les candidats de tous les
présidents pardon sortants qui se
représentent c'était pareil pour giscard
d'estaing qui avait pas su avoir un
nouveau message alors qu'il avait il
avait été flamboyant en 1974 avec un
message précis ça a été le cas il ya que
mitterrand qui a finalement réussi ce
coup là avec sa lettre en quoi ces
patientes qui avaient en cohabitation
mais bon chirac n'avait pas réussi six
as réussi effectivement à faire rêver
trouver un nouveau si vous voulez un
nouveau mantra il lui manquait un mantra
il avait évidemment en 2017 et là c'est
ce qu'il sait ce qui lui a manqué alors
est ce que il n'a pas joué par facilité
moi je trouve qu'il a était un peu trop
les mains dans les poches dans cette
histoire c'est travailler oui c'est sûr
qu'il était très haut et que donc il a
cru que c'était une affaire pliée que le
game était terminée voilà mais c'est
vrai que en fait moi je pense qu'il
avait quand même un projet très clair il
a dit il a pensé que ça suffisait
d'ailleurs je vais vous faire une
réforme sur la dépendance on va
transformer l'école l'hôpital etc et
vous allez payer avec l'allongement de
ne travailler plus exercé par travailler
plus pour gagner plus contrairement à
sarkozy c'était on va tout changer mais
vous allez le payer et je crois que ça
s'est heurtée avec le président des
riches scelleront tout le monde sait que
finalement il ya beaucoup d'argent qui a
été dépensé que beaucoup de gens se sont
énormément enrichis il ya quand même une
progression des richesses considérables
pendant son mandat et que la proposition
qui nous fait c'est pas du tout de
rééquilibrer tout ça mais c'est de dire
à ceux qui travaillent vous allez
travailler plus donc toutes les
transformations qui sont attendus c'est
les travailleurs les salariés qui vont
partir plus tard à la retraite et je
pense que c'était un vrai discours
politique mais un vrai discours
politique ne pouvait pas rencontré
l'adhésion de ces pas possible à rolle
d'argent il ya de la fébrilité en macro
nier aujourd'hui parce que on nous a
beaucoup dit attention marine le pen
fait très bonne campagne les proches du
président est ce que on essaye de quoi
de chouettes faire peur de mobiliser son
camp lorsqu'elle est au contraire ça
pétoche je pense qu'elles les deux je
pense qu'il y en a qui sont réellement
inquiet en disant rien n'est jamais joué
c'est vrai et donc il faut faire
extrêmement attention et d'autres qui
sont probablement un peu moins inquiet
en disant non toute façon la
marine le pen passera pas mais moi ce
qui me frappe c'est que
je trouve qu'il ya un peu ce que disait
un peu il fait rare il ya beaucoup de
désinvolture moi je trouve dans cette
espagne de la part d' emmanuel macron
parce qu'on a l'impression qu'on alors
il n'était pas là d'accord il y avait la
guerre ans l'ukraine veut dire au fond
ayant pour la démocratie en ukraine
alors il faut la défendre en france et
faire des meetings en disant voilà la
démocratie et le vieillissement d'être
un peu avec les gens un peu de proximité
alors là on a eu le sentiment quand même
que il arrivait un peu à la dernière
minute avec un truc un peu bâclé la
lettre aux français franchement un ça
m'a impressionné personne et ensuite la
hand est dans la dernière ligne droite
il nous fait halte au fascisme
c'est dans l'intérêt du parisien ce
matin dans le figaro a aussi déjà hier
bon avec le conseil se sent
un peu éculé on n'est ce pas le problème
c'est qu'on sait très bien gérer à court
d'idées bah voilà exactement et puis
surtout c'est dangereux parce qu'on sait
très bien que ce discours là bien
marcher sous mitterrand je suis la balle
est donc allé un président candidat a
désinvolte et à court d'idées ça ça
clashe pas mal alors on va avancer parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de candidats
j'aimerais vous entendre on va parler de
marine le pen on va parler de jean luc
mélenchon et d'eric zemmour pourquoi
marine le pen et jean luc mélenchon
n'ont pas pâti de leur poutine au chili
c'est la grande question de cette
élection avant de vous entendre petit
rappel des faits avec miles morales a
dit mir poutine la figure d'exemple
dirigeants modèle marine le pen jean-luc
mélenchon eric zemmour n'ont jamais
caché leur admiration
mais après le début de la guerre en
ukraine poutine devient l'infréquentable
condamné unanimement par les candidats
ce qui pousse à des revirements le
virage est bien pris pour jean luc
mélenchon lui qui félicitait vladimir
poutine pour son intervention en syrie
en 2016 il s'en est discrètement
désolidariser nous avons un problème
énorme avec vladimir poutine c'est la
première fois que quelqu'un sur le
continent européen violent les
frontières du voisin massacre des gens
et se livrent à des crimes de guerre
marine le pen est aussi à la manoeuvre
son discours honte immigration est
abandonnée quand l'accueil des réfugiés
ukrainien devient une évidence la voie
de secours devient le pouvoir d'achat à
l'heure où la préoccupation est
davantage sur le prix de l'essence du
puissant allié qu'elle avait rencontré
en marge de la présidentielle de 2017
poutine devient l'indéfendable ma
position ça a été d'abord de condamner
la russie lorsqu'elle a envahi l'ukraine
de mal la manière la plus claire qui
soit cette agression armée et est
inadmissible au regard du droit
international
nous avons d'ailleurs voté au parlement
européen une condamnation extrêmement
ferme de cette agression russe
al'inverse eric zemmour lui qui rêvait
d'un poutine français en 2018 n'a pas
pris le bon pari le problème de
l'ukraine n'est pas si vous voulez que
la russie menace d'une invasion je n'y
crois pas la russie n'a une dizaine de
milliers de personnes qui d'un soldat
russe qui sont postés à l'austère la
russie je vous donne le propagent aux
pros le pari n'envahira pas l'ukraine
mais les exactions dans la ville
ukrainienne de butch à force le candidat
au revirement si vous aviez vladimir
poutine en face de vous demain matin
vous lui diriez quoi
celui dirais que c'est que ces odieux
criminels infâme et qu'
il il salit l'image même de son pays
eric zemmour persiste dans son programme
anti immigration pas de place pour les
ukrainiens ça veut dire que je préfère
qu'il soit en pologne pour d'abord parce
que la pole les accueils que c'est sous
leurs voisins et qu'ils pourront ainsi
plus facilement rentrer chez eux quand
la guerre sera finie donc vous seriez le
seul parmi les candidats ne pas vouloir
accueillir des réfugiés la tuile être
civile dit j'assume un mauvais calcul
qui se ressent dans les sondages depuis
le début de la guerre eric zemmour a
divisé par deux ses intentions de vote
tandis que marine le pen et jean luc
mélenchon ont gagné 8 et 6 % alors on va
commencer par marine le pen puisque
après mail macron c'est elle qui est en
deuxième position très près d'ailleurs
l'écart se resserre dans cette enquête
ipsos elle est à 23% en un petit mois
elle après entre 8 et 10 points elle est
allée il ya cinq ans se faire adouber
par vladimir poutine au kremlin elle
aurait pu sombrer à cause de cette seule
image ça n'a pas été le cas pourquoi
parce qu'il ya un double effet poutine
et à l'effet guerre est donc ce qui est
en effet sont apparus comme des poutines
haut la tour des poutines au fil on est
un petit peu de mal à se redresser
eric zemmour n'a pas réussi jean luc
mélenchon ça lui a pris un peu de temps
mais il ya le deuxième effet poutine qui
a l'effet sur le pouvoir d'achat et le
pouvoir d'achat c'est le thème au coeur
de la campagne marine le pen donc le
fait que la guerre provoque une hausse
du prix du carburant peut-être demain du
prix de la farine des pâtes etc ça remet
marine le pen au centre d'un débat dont
elle aurait dû être évacuées à cause de
son lien avec poutine liens politiques
lien financier puisqu'elle a encore dell
doit encore de l'argent à une banque qui
est proche du pouvoir c'est sa meilleure
campagne vous diriez de michel a choisi
le pouvoir d'achat d'autres lui disait
il faut revenir aux fondamentaux
immigration insécurité elle a continué
elle a fait ce pari très tôt c'est sa
meilleure campagne parce qu'elle a eu de
la chance quelque part ça aurait pu ne
pas être ce thème elle ne pouvait pas
changer ni de personnalité d'un seul
coup redevenir d'extrême droite comme
son père parce qu'ils avaient la
concurrence zemmour elle se serait
enfoncé encore plus ni de thème c'est à
dire repartir sur l'immigration
obsessionnelle alors qu'elle avait
choisi le pouvoir d'achat pour rester
sur un électorat populaire donc elle a
attendu ça aurait pu ne pas tourner en
sa faveur et zemmour pourrait être deux
points de vente m mais il se trouve que
les événements l'ont favorisé de ce côté
là avoir la chance c'est aussi un talent
politique pas d'accord avec va pas du
tout moi je pense d'abord marine le pen
n'a pas eu de la chance ça fait cinq ans
qu'elle ait pris la stratégie d'élargir
son champ d'intervention et de ne pas se
centrer sur la question des migrations
et donc elle a travaillé tous les sujets
elle leur a mis une cohérence et dire
qu'elle n'a pas changé cohérence elle
reste une candidate d'extrême droite
mail elle a élargi sa patte ses enfants
des classes populaires qui va dire go
s'il y avait bien sûr mais non facture
voter enfin il n'y a pas de face et un
peu plus compliqué que ça mais en tout
cas ce qu'elle a fait c'est qu'elle a
cherché à être justement prête à capable
de camper sur tous les terrains c'est
vrai les zemmour oui il aurait pu la
norme et non mais justement moi je ne
crois pas du tout pesé mais on pouvait à
tuer moi ce que je pense exe moore est
un idéologue c'est pas du tout un
politique c'est un homme qui est venu
affirmer une position et qu' il
d'ailleurs il a continué de l'affirmer
quoi qu'il arrive une contre vents et
marées et il est venu pour posé des
banderilles sur le chemin du futur la
recomposition de la droite la
transformation idéologique du pays
marine le pen finalement ça lui va très
bien il fait le travail des broussailles
autour il pose des idéologies des
thématiques d'extrême droite et elle
salue donc c'est la voiture balai vous
relevez maison depuis florian philippot
qu'ils ont choisi cette stratégie fait
je veux dire ça vient à peine d'arriver
ils apparurent claquant la porte oui et
j'entends bien mais en même temps la
position tout terrain et sociale de
marine le pen remonte à loin c'était
bien la position sociale et mes jambes
sur l'euro il ya eu changement sur
l'ours est pour ça qu ils se sont fâchés
avec filippo mais par contre sur le
reste le fait qu'elle se prépare à être
en situation sur tous les sujets et en
essayant et ben ça c'est de fait c'est
bien devant et saluer le la ferme idée
faire sur les mallettes remplace qu'il
ya quand même beaucoup de choses qui ont
changé sur l'image
pas du tout d'accord avec ce qu'il ya
des dix évidemment qu'elle a de la
chance elle a une chance folle c'est que
eric zemmour s'est pris les pieds dans
le tapis non pas tellement d'ailleurs
sur poutine ou pas poutine mais sur les
réfugiés ukrainien c'est absolument pour
lui c'était
signe d'inhumanité 2 alors même si
c'était cohérent avec j'ai pensé je
saigne le nom distance et la cohérent
pas cohérent oui les aider c'était des
orthodoxes son écurie ça peut être aussi
à l'étranger
on a vu des étrangers là où ses
électeurs vous voyez des cousins oui oui
il a cru que pour ces électeurs se
seraient des étrangers et et c'est pas
le cas mais on sélectionne celles ci
dans une des ailes elle avait quand même
assez incroyable parce qu'alors il
s'agit pas de lui tresser des lauriers
mais sur un plan strictement politique
elle n'a pas tellement changé ce sont le
contenu de son discours pas tellement à
part l'histoire de l'euro sur le reste
elle est quand même très version de bild
17 en accentuant effectivement sur le
côté social et sur le côté pouvoir
d'achat plus que jamais l annulation sa
rencontre le bazar
k o qui a en europe actuellement ça
c'est la première des choses mais rendez
vous compte que qu'il fallait avoir un
sac de sacrée force de caractère pour se
relever du débat de l'entre-deux tours
de 17 première chose et nous y est bon
pour elle je vous rappelle le l'automne
qu'elle a passés ou coptes zemmour et a
pendant un mois on ne l'a pas vu elle
savait pas si quelle campagne elle
devait faire elle était complètement
perdue a réalisé qu'elle était au
contact l'honorable ça ne sert à rien du
tout elle était féru essais et beaucoup
de ses soutiens disait il faut tu
recommences a radicalisé son discours ce
qu'il est en train de piquer la place et
finalement elle a gardé son slogan de
campagne je vous rappelle son affiche
quand on l'a vu à la sortie de l'été
avec cette affiche dans les champs
liberté sérieux on se disait que c'était
pas tellement en conformité avec ce
qu'elle allait pouvoir nous dire et en
fait ça a marché alors carole barjon un
petit mot peut-être sur marine le pen et
puis on passe à jean luc mélenchon oui
non c'est juste que effectivement
qu'elle est prête est ce que vous diriez
ça parce qu'elle répète à longueur
d'interview je suis prête est ce qu'elle
est vraiment prête tout tout tout ces
cadres sont passés chez et mot est ce
qu'elle est prête à gouverner c'est tout
cas c'est la question que se poseront
les français effectivement entre les
deux tours si elle est qualifiée pour le
pour le second parce qu'effectivement on
demandera à ce moment là ce qui est
laura et ça on n'a pas la réponse n'est
pas évidente absolument alors jean-luc
mélenchon jean luc mélenchon le
professionnel troisième campagne
le rhéteur vraiment un art oratoire on a
vu ces big thing olfactif avec ses
énormes écrans géants les les
hologrammes et il a aussi beaucoup
changé sur le tempérament se finit le
bruit et la fureur il a bossé ils se
rêvent en 3 troisième deuxième fois il
espère être qualifié pour l'instant il
est 3e on va le voir sur sur les
sondages aujourd'hui on apprend
christiane taubira appelle à voter pour
lui ça peut peser oui ça pèsera mais ça
ne sera pas assez parce qu'être un
rhéteur ne suffit pas il faut être un
rassembleur et il n'est pas rassembleur
il arrive au bout de son projet
personnel et idéologiques et il va
l'atteindre ce projet c'est pas d'entrer
à l'elysée s'est tué le ps depuis 2008
peut-être même deux avant depuis 2007 le
congrès de brest il a cette envie de
tuer le ps il va y parvenir ça y est
c'est fait est-ce que ça permet de
gagner non ni à la présidentielle il va
sans doute lui manquait pour être au
second tour les trois points que fabien
roussel va avoir il avait été un
rassembleur plutôt que lundi viseur
alors ils payent c'est de ne pas avoir
par mille unités voilà il paie de
n'avoir jamais cherché même l'union il
n'aura même pas adressé la parole ni à
la frange des écologistes qui lui était
favorable ni socialiste ni aux
communistes et il va peut-être dimanche
soir se mordre les doigts parce que
c'est peut-être ça qui va le prêter sans
avoir besoin parce qu'en revanche il ya
les législatives derrière et là il peut
lui même être puni c'est à dire être
rayé de la carte législatives haïti le
reste de la gauche seuls deux candidats
il va se présenter ailleurs se présente
en favori ou ça à paris mais il a fait
une fin de campagne remarquable qui est
à l'opposé de tout ce qu'il a fait
pendant le quinquennat wisair qui s'est
radicalisée pendant ce quinquennat alors
qu'il devait ramasser la mise après
l'élection de 2017 ou à gauche il y
avait pas grand monde et lui était là il
avait fait un bon score et il a arrêté
de radicaliser son discours ce qui lui a
valu d'ailleurs lille le le rejet d'une
partie de la gauche est là à la fin de
son de cette campagne il s'est radouci
aux moindres détails la ronde ils seront
10 décembre dans le fond et dans un
souci qui les deux assurent ils aiment
la police est alors oui c'est là ils
peur il peut seulement savoir des doigts
parce qu'en fait ils se il aurait pu
être au deuxième tour de cette élection
m il aurait pu tant pis pour lui mais là
s'en mordent les doigts moi je pense que
la difficulté que jean luc mélenchon a
devant lui c'est la faiblesse de la
gauche dans son ensemble
on a trois pôles désormais on a un pôle
de droite avec emmanuel macron en chef
un peu pécresse dedans et puis on a un
pôle d'extrême droite et un pool de
gauche et le pôle de gauche c'est le
plus faible des trois donc ça serait
quand même un exploit qu'il parfait lors
du faible
attendez je ce que je veux dire c'est
que le parti socialiste s'en est occupé
tout seul je viens la très mauvaise
campagne de haine hidalgo et la très
médiocre kampala
là vous enjambez parce qu'on va
continuer dans l'ordre on va parler de
la gauche dans un instant mais on va
continuer après jean-luc mélenchon après
eric zemmour arrive valérie pécresse et
là on a envie de vous entendre parce que
c'est quand même un séisme pour la
droite regardez d'abord ce sujet de léo
se elle avait toutes les cartes en main
d'une certaine façon après sa victoire à
la primaire et puis ça s'est compliqué
regarde
le 4 décembre tout semble possible pour
valérie pécresse intronisée candidate de
la droite par la primaire elle fait
aussitôt un bond dans les sondages en
deuxième position talonnons emmanuel
macron mais en fait le plus dur reste à
faire faire parler ses convictions
imprimés saline dans un parti qui penche
très à droite alors elle durcit le ton
croit bon de reprendre la formule du
kärcher de nicolas sarkozy
première faute puis elle enchaîne avec
un méga meeting au zénith où elle
utilise le terme de grand remplacement
rassemblement qu'elle qualifiera elle
même de rater la chute est inexorable
elle dévisse dans les sondages 13 puis
moins de 10%
la candidate espère le soutien de
nicolas sarkozy
mais il ne viendra pas c'est le grand
absent les militants lui font sentir au
point de le huer porte de versailles
début avril nicolas sarkozy
[Musique]
aujourd'hui autour de 8% dans les
sondages valérie pécresse a annoncé
qu'elle ne donnerait pas de consignes de
vote pour le second tour mais elle
indiquera tout de même pour qui elle ira
voter
alors valérie pécresse carole barjon l
etat ubi 2,5 pour cent dans ce sondage
ipsos est ce qu'elle a fait la mauvaise
campagne est ce que c'est une question
de stratégie
dès le départ après après sa victoire à
la primaire il ya d'abord une difficulté
de positionnement évidemment dans la
mesure où elle est comment elle gagne la
primaire de la droite un moment où eric
zemmour a déjà fait sa percée fulgurante
et très haut donc de toutes façons elle
est confrontée dès le départ un problème
de positionnement sa campagne où elle
est au fond écartelé les électeurs aient
l'air qu'elle représente en a quand même
donné le sentiment d'avoir choisi un
puisque elle s'est très vite affiché
avec eric ciotti ya une distance où il
karcher le green remplacement oui mais
il ya eu plusieurs comment dire
plusieurs étapes j'irai même qui a eu de
zig zag même si ça c'est pas vraiment vu
vous de celle et en même temps qu'elle
appartenait ce but elle part quand même
extrêmement effectivement à droite sur
les thèmes régalien l'immigration la
sécurité et ensuite en janvier elle
estime avoir crantée comme on dit sur
ces sujets là on se dit oh là là oh la
la c'est vrai qu'à droite il ya quand
même voilà des électeurs libéraux qui
sont tentés par la politique de macron
et même qui était d'ailleurs des anciens
électeurs fionie de fillon de 2017 qui
était passé chez makro il faut les
récupérer donc là on a eu droit un
changement de discours est beaucoup plus
axé sur l'économie et puis vous noterez
que là en tout cinq campagnes
c'est non pas retour l'immigration sur
le site cissé de retour immigration
sécurité et c'est surtout qu'elle
martèle depuis une semaine je suis une
femme de droite je suis à droite elle a
envoyé aujourd'hui une lettre aux
lecteurs de valeurs actuelles
non mais ça ça en dit long mais tout le
problème est qu'elles aient à faire ça
parce que ça veut dire qu'elle n'a pas
réussi en réalité à convaincre les
électeurs de droite qu'elle était une
femme lui manquait un message aucun des
changes de rêver un message très rapide
je fêterai le bourg elle n'avait pas de
message qu'est ce qu'elle a dit valérie
pécresse on sait pas ce qu'elle a dit
c'était pourtant simple avec 1 ap 1 et
moore qui dit c'était mieux avant il
fallait dire c'était mieux après est
déroulé cela mieux après je sais macro
qui fait ça mais oui mais elle réduit et
lui a piqué toutes ces idées justement
macron sur sur un tas de sujets il est
venu et qu'elle n'aurait pas dû sur la
gouvernance sur la méthode au fond elle
est proche d'un certain nombre de sujets
sur le plan économique de maquereaux et
de dire avec moi ce sera pas c'est pas
de la même façon plus marquée au niveau
voilà de l'équipe de la prise de
décision - de verticalité ça suffit pas
la méthode s'est trompé sur la fonction
elle a cru qu'on allait lire un super
premier ministre super compétents dont
fallait de bon sur tous les dossiers
mais si c'était ça mendès-france et
rocard aurait été président et on voit
bien que ces talk show ça de vista est
une incarnation une vision et puis la
passion inventé le pécresse isme c'est
un mot qui ne s'est jamais un invité
dans la campagne
cette espèce de ça va ça vient des idées
parce qu'il ya pas que la queue du chien
des sondages qui font ça va ça vienne il
est aussi elle
aurait dû dire au revoir définitivement
à cette génération sarkozy fillon et
inventer une nouvelle droite avec une
nouvelle pensée de droite oui facettes
en revoir à l'ancienne droite et puis
d'affirmer une droite conservatrice
droite dans ses bottes ça a été belle
amie et ça fait 6 % oui mais quand elles
habitent jeudi les américaines mais ce
que je veux attirer % c'est qu'en fait
oui bel ami elle n'a pas réussi sert qu
on lui demande d' inventer quelque chose
que la droite n'a pas réussi à faire
depuis dix ans dans la nuit mais c'est
pas la seule on a l'impression que le
voilà on est tellement dans la haie dans
la presse est faux tout il faut tout
reconstruire c'est dès dimanche soir dès
dimanche ça va exploser il va falloir
reconstruire bien je l'écouté le le tout
derrière la droite a la chance la
circonscription à quelque chose c'est
sos que ces méchants c'est parce que est
là un maillage d'élus locaux très fort
le plus fort de tous les partis français
mais sinon ils sont dans le même état je
dirais avec peut-être des idées qui sont
plus porteuses mais dans le même état
que le parti socialiste catherine c'est
sako nicolas sarkozy mais dans la
corbeille de mariage à maquereau il lui
dit tu as ta pas de partis moi j'en ai
un non non quand il dit je bosse bien
sûr moi c'est ce que je pense et que mme
un maquereau est tout seul il n'a pas
réussi à se rassurer et lui il a abusé
culture asile propos mariage il propose
un mariage ev3 dire le premier ira là
bas durant ces six n'y pourra rien parce
que ça explique d'abord et ensuite la
corbeille de mariage elle dépend du
score
obtiennent à faire les candidats et de
l'ordre d'arrivée pour que si le 2 et
léry pécresse est derrière eric zemmour
c'est pas la même chose si on ajoute à
ça la gauche on a commencé à en parler
entre yannick jadot anne hidalgo et
fabien roussel le total est à peine à
plus de 10% va s'arrêter sur anne
hidalgo et fabien roussel dans ce sujet
de doléances
j'ai décidé d'être candidate à la
présidence de la république
on prononçant ces mots là maire de paris
n'imaginait sans doute pas vivre un tel
chemin de croix crédité de 7 à 9% dans
les sondages la candidate ps s'interroge
devant une primaire populaire qui gagne
en visibilité y aller ne pas y aller
anne hidalgo se lance avant de se
raviser sans la participation des verts
la primaire de la gauche a perdu tout
son sens et cette élection avant le
premier tour qu'il devait nous unir ils
ne l'ont pas voulu alors la page est
tournée je défendrai notre projet et les
françaises et les penseurs franchement
qu'importe le 30 janvier la primaire
populaire sacre christiane taubira une
candidate de plus à gauche mais pas pour
longtemps elle sort du jeu un mois plus
tard faute de parrainages mais pas de
quoi faire remonter le score d'anne
hidalgo au contraire celle-ci dégringole
autour de 2 % dans les sondages cette
campagne aura donc fini d'achever un ps
à bout de souffle al'inverse le pc lui a
repris des couleurs consolidé à 3 et 9 %
ré enchanter par fabien roussel la
révélation de la campagne en partie
grâce à son sens de la formule un bon
vin une bonne viande un bon fromage pour
moi c'est la gastronomie française
épicurien et défenseurs des traditions
culinaires oms elle se fait étriper par
les siens à gauche sans jamais perdre le
sens de l'humour qui coûte cher c'est sa
théorie du ruissellement
et bien moi je vous propose une autre
théorie le roussel morts
maintenant à moi elles sont
l'internationale et la marseillaise
ces cocos et cocorico à gauche les
grandes manoeuvres sont déjà lancés
objectif penser l'après élection et un
nouveau mouvement social démocrate
on va commencer par fabien roussel
révélation franchement c'est c'est
mérité oui c'est demi s'est pas non plus
à la révélation d'un personnage le
communisme joyeux sympathie que
franchouillard bons vivants ces sources
heureux c'est quand même non mais c'est
le temps des cerises et donc il ya cette
mythologie joyeuse de la fête dans le
communisme sauf que derrière il ya un
programme qui restait pendant ce marché
staline voilà et c'est pour ça qui fait
que 3 % parce qu'avec un tel personnage
aussi sympathique seniors feront vous
avez dans notre imaginaire celui qui est
rusé qui est malin qui est joyeux est
pas méchant du tout mais quelqu'un qui
lutte à sept-îles l'espiègle élevé avec
ce personnage là il devrait être 8 à 9
les plus gai que jadot est évidemment
plus enthousiasmant hidalgo pourquoi n'y
est-il qu'à 3 parce que derrière il ya
un truc qui s'appelle le communisme le
marxisme léninisme sur lequel ils n'ont
jamais fait leur aggiornamento il le
payant il a du mal à placer staline
d'ailleurs
exactement contre échos sur staline sur
cette petite question camarades pas
camarade lui ça lui a coûté cher ça lui
a coûté très certainement cher et c'est
pas tout à fait un hasard ce que je veux
dire c'est qu'en effet il a du mal avec
le rapport à l'histoire est en effet
être communiste comme on gère son la
relation passée c'est un peu ça reste
compliqué et il a dû il est du mail en
fait aussi à projeter le communisme à
dire ce qu'il est aujourd'hui pour le
21e siècle on ne sait pas au terme de
cette campagne on comprend que il ya des
communistes en france et moi je crois
qu'il n'y a pas de gauche sans qu'il y
ait des communistes et qu'ils aient leur
place à ça me parait il faut il faut
partie de l'espace de la gauche mais on
n'a pas tout à fait compris ce qu'il
devait apporter on a bien compris qui
défend des produire français et le cd
centrale
nucléaire voilà hélas et voilà
mais c'est pas complètement anecdotique
1 comme question je ne
vois là ça n'a pas pris par ailleurs je
crois qu'il a fait une faute à mon avis
est qu'il s'est plu mais s'est démarqué
des luttes de la jeunesse sont entrés en
campagne en allant à cette manifestation
de la police je pense qu'elle a
profondément heurté une partie de la
gauche et beaucoup de gens dans la
jeunesse qui celui qui lutte contre les
violences policières il ne s'intéresse
pas aux luttes féministes il ne
s'intéresse pas aux lutte contre le
racisme et les discriminations d'une
façon générale il a fait aussi une sorte
de marque marqueur tournant sur les
questions de laïcité qui la revend sais
que
tu es biokou il doit parler d'eux mais
du coup c'est couper d'une partie
d'aider des jeunes et des luttes contre
tous en voyage salini là le discours de
chevènement et ça aurait pu marcher il
nous reste à peu près quatre minutes
trente pour balayer à la fois le
naufrage des socialistes et on dirait un
petit mot sur les trotskistes après
carole barjon campagne impitoyable pour
anne hidalgo est ce que c'est de sa
faute uniquement à l où est-ce qu'on
comme le disait christophe barbier voilà
mélenchon a enterré le ps est au fond il
va falloir tout réinventer derrière moi
je pense pas que mélenchon est enterré
le ps je pense que le ps s'est
autodétruit pour commencer et ça ça
vient d'assez loin parce que
je moi je ne mets pas ça tous sur le
combler
moi ça vient d'avant en souvenez vous de
l'élection de 2002 en 2002
lionel jospin ait éliminé et c'est jean
marie le pen qui est au second tour
c'est un séisme c'est un séisme ç'aurait
dû
provoquer mais des discussions des
reconstructions des années c'est ce
collectif et nous la soirée y est parti
socialiste ne sont pas rêver il n'y en a
rien été il n'y a pas eu de boulot voilà
donc du coup on a l'impression que
hidalgo par non c'est pas du tout pour
elle a connu avec un essai néo les
heures de queue de comète là c'est c'est
le résultat d'années de dénis sur les
sujets qui intéressent les français
d'abord et puis 2-2 d'absence de travail
donc elle paye tout ça et tout ça par
ailleurs je pense qu'elle a sous-estimé
totalement ce que ce qu'elle a fait à
paris les français sont tout à fait au
courant parce que c'est la capitale de
leur pays et je pense que ça le look
elle a aussi une part de responsabilité
personnelle christophe wargnier cerny
dago s'est trompé d'année fallait
attendre 2027 tenir sa promesse de ne
rester que mr gérer les jeux olympiques
et est la femme de 2027 bon ali est allé
c'était pas la bonne année en plus ce
n'était pas les bonnes propositions
doubler le salaire des profs etc c'était
pas la bonne idéologie parce que le
socialisme non plus n'a pas inventé pour
l'instant l'idéologie qui défendent les
classes populaires les ailes et ceux qui
sont victimes de du capitalisme
postindustrielle ils ont pas ils sont
pas assez retourner vers 7h mais moi je
pense qu'il ya aussi eu un mot qui doit
être éliminé du langage et le mot de la
synthèse ils se sont tus et avec la
synthèse permanente et d'une certaine
façon lâche pas d'accord c'est drôle
parce que la socialiste a marche pas
mais le et en même temps ma couenne et
ça marche oui mais c'est pas tout à fait
là une addition l'accord de doha le
responsable de cette de cet échec de la
synthèse c'est justement françois
hollande qu'il l'a fait perdurer trop
longtemps faut pas oublier qu'il a été
premier secrétaire du parti socialiste
avant d'être premier ministre mais en
2009 il voyait grand bond lui et il
avait un boulevard avec l'urgence
climatique il n'a pas forcément su
l'exploiter nexhat au quatrième trio on
entend au fond les vergers un peu du
désespoir il veut convaincre jusqu'au
bout qu'est ce qu'il paye lui il est
aspiré par le naufrage de la gauche ou
tout simplement n'imprime pas moi je
prendrais de rousseau dit on n'avait pas
de projet de récits on a vendu des
chaudières elle a été exclue pour ça oui
je pense que c'était pas faux comme
diagnostic c'est à dire qu'ils n'ont pas
réussi à avoir une proposition moi aussi
je m'interroge franchement qu'est ce que
je retiens de la campagne de yannick
jadot on sait qu'ils les écologistes on
sait qu'il est inquiet pour le
réchauffement climatique et nous le
sommes avec lui mais au fond qu'est ce
qu'ils proposent comme acte fort qui va
nous permettre d'enrayer cette situation
qui nous inquiète et nous alarme mais on
ne s'est pas pressé c'est la rénovation
thermique il vous le dirai oui mais là
non mais c'est pas ça annonce france à
trèbes en dollars et venant d'ailleurs
justement je pense que ce qu'il n'a pas
réussi c'est que il y avait le sujet du
pouvoir d'achat il aurait dû mieux
vendre la question écologique comme un
moyen de retrouver un peu de pouvoir
d'achat énorme tant que l'énergie est
encore de lui l'énergie l'exacte e mans
le acheté à côté de chez soi etc il n'a
pas su le faire et au total on a
simplement un des indes récit un pied
bon et bien on est inquiet avec lui mais
on veut des solutions alors pour des
raisons d'équilibré absolue on va vous
entendre encore une toute petite poignée
de secondes sur ce qu'on appelle une
tradition française deux candidats
trotskistes et oui et puis un candidat
pas comme les autres regardez moi je lis
plan b le plan b c'est les révoltes
c'est la lutte sociale il faut qu'on
s'organise et puis le plan b c'est la
robe construction d'une gauche radicale
anticapitaliste
il faut qu'on discute de ça on peut pas
se contenter de discuter de l'horizon au
10 avril au 24 avril sans envisager la
suite parce qu'on sait que mâcon s'ils
gagnent ivan ou flingué en sexy c'est le
pen qui gagne elle va nous flinguer
comment se défend comment se réorganise
comment on arrive à préparer la riposte
un peu comme aujourd'hui la colère peut
éclater en corse ou comme elle peut
éclater dans deux endroits j'ai dit que
nous ne pouvions pas continuer au pays
des droits de l'homme à vivre sur monde
aussi financier est ce que le parti
social est sous représenté un petit peu
aurait dû lire depuis longtemps et qui
n'a pas dit et que nous ne pouvons pas
supporter c'est un de ces hiérarques à
la tête de nos plus grands médias
heureusement que france inter le domaine
public j'espère qu'il restera neuf ans
continuera aussi
pour conclure ce débat vrai les vrais
les vrais candidat antisystème ils sont
lassés artaud et époux tout ce que
paient eux ils veulent pas été lu ils
veulent que lier un troisième tour
social qui est la révolution et que le
le pouvoir soit soit balayée croire la
salle c'est un peu le même style
d'ailleurs aussi et rural mais
heureusement on écoute et merci
infiniment dans l'exercice contre 1
l'égalité strict des temps de parole
merci de nous avoir livré votre
expertise aller voter
la campagne s'arrête à minuit ce soir
essayez d'être au rendez vous de ce
grand rendez vous démocratique merci
infiniment alors je voulais quand même
signaler la production littéraire la
dernière est allée foisonnante de
christophe barbier à la recherche du
héros perdus elise et 2022 au fond c'est
ou racine ou corneille allez-y en
librairie et puis une certaine idée de
la france c'est un peu un bébé lcpc
qu'on peut dire à la faveur des grands
entretiens 10 réart de toute une série
de personnalités ça va deux génies
bastié alain finkielkraut en passant par
catherine nay ou michel winock vous
allez découvrir ces grands entretiens
aux éditions du rocher merci à vous on
va s'arrêter à présent sur la situation
en ukraine nouvelles sanctions
européennes nouvelle offensive qui
s'annonce très violente à l'est du pays
dans le donbass on va accueillir notre
invité dominique moïsi on mais avant
cela le point sur les derniers
développements de ce conflit avec
thibaut inc
tout un symbole
abuja hier le drapeau ukrainien est
hissé sur le fronton de la mairie pour
la première fois depuis que l'armée
russe a quitté la ville laissant
derrière elle le massacre que le monde
connaît désormais à quelques mètres de
là un haut responsable de l'onu venus
sur place promet que ces crimes ne
resteront pas impunis
le monde est profondément choquée la
prochaine étape est l' enquête
une enquête qui sera longue et difficile
l'horreur de boudhha et elles isolées il
est à craindre que non selon volodymyr
et l'ins qui le pi resterait encore à
découvrir à bord awdian cas toujours
près de kiev
la situation serait encore bien plus
horrible a déclaré le président
ukrainien chez ici dans presque toutes
les rues se trouve ce que le monde a vu
à butch à après le retrait des troupes
russes la cruauté et des crimes
terribles des crimes qui ont précipité
de nouvelles sanctions de la communauté
internationale
hier l'assemblée générale des nations
unies ainsi décidé d'écarter la russie
du conseil des droits de l'homme
la décision rare prise par cette
assemblée aujourd'hui envoie un signal
fort espérons qu'elle contribuera à
prévenir et à décourager d'autres
violations des droits de l'homme
human rights
l'europe aussi continuent de durcir le
ton l'union a décidé hier d'un cinquième
train de sanctions les ports européens
seront fermés aux navires russes et un
embargo a été décrété sur le charbon
venant de russie dans le même temps les
européens vont augmenter de 500 millions
d'euros leur financement pour fournir
des armes à l'ukraine insuffisant selon
le chef de la diplomatie ukrainienne
venu adresser un message très clair à
l'otan hier
notre demande est très simple nous
voulons trois choses des armes des arts
et des arts en droit passe
si la demande est si pressante c'est que
le temps semble compté les trois
prochaines semaines pourrait être
décisive le retrait russe de la région
de kiev et du nord de l'ukraine
s'accompagne d'un le déploiement massif
des forces russes dans l'est une
offensive massive se prépare les jours
qui viennent seront la dernière chance
pour les civils d'évacuer avertissent
les autorités ukrainiennes jose nous
continuons à nous préparer à une
activité encore plus brutale des
occupants dans les directions est et sud
nous savons ce qu'ils vont faire dans le
donbass la russie qui concentre une
quantité importante de militaires et
d'équipements d'après le président
emmanuel macron qui continue de
s'entretenir avec lui vladimir poutine
va chercher une victoire pour le 9 mai
jour de fête nationale en russie il est
à peu près sûr que pour le président
poutine le 9 mai doit être un jour de
victoire et donc je pense qu'ils vont
concentrer leurs efforts dans le nom bas
je pense que nous allons vivre des
scènes très difficile pour cette raison
le président français dit craindre le
pire
d'ici là
bon soir dominique moïsi et je remercie
infiniment d'être parmi nous ce soir
vous êtes un gros spécialiste des
relations internationales elle dazio
politique fondateur de l'ifri et
conseiller spécial de l'institut
montaigne commençons donc par cette date
du 9 mai dont le président m'a chrono 10
coupons elle est fondatrice la victoire
1945 penser que c'est le nouvel agenda
de de vladimir poutine obtenir une
victoire dans dans le donbass pour pour
le 9 mai oui je crois qu'il faut bien
comprendre la signification du 9 mai
d'abord ce n'est pas lui mais c'est le
neuf c'est une date spécifique qui
traduit la victoire de l'urss qui a
disparu contre un ennemi le nazisme
c'est
le moment de rédemption de l'urss c'est
là où elle peut se regarder dans les
yeux et dire j'ai lutté contre un
adversaire pire que moi donc
effectivement vous confirmer que cette
date pas être importantes et à la pac
d'ailleurs orthodoxe avant en avril les
habitants du donbass fuient en masse la
région que l'armée russe cherche à
prendre en tenaille on peut s'attendre à
une offensive russe massive tout cela
malgré toutes les pertes subies jusqu'à
présent dans l'armée russe parce que
elles sont considérables les
renseignements américains nous indique
quand même des pertes matérielles et un
soldat très importante oui on parle de
pertes qui sont déjà supérieures à ce
qu'étaient les pertes
soviétique en afghanistan pendant dix
ans de 1979 à 1989 donc on est alors on
ne sait pas exactement il ya une
incertitude sur les chiffres
oui mais toute la question est de savoir
si en se concentrant sur le dombass ils
vont réussir est ce qu'ils ont appris
de leurs échecs de l'or entre guillemets
naïveté ou est-ce qu'au fond du compte
on va retrouver les mêmes causes
produisant les mêmes effets un échec
dans le donbass le chef de l'otan a dit
que cette guerre pourrait durer des mois
voire des années
ça veut dire qu'il en a sous le pied
d'une certaine façon vladimir poutine on
ne peut pas parié sur une fracture de
cette dictature d'ici là on ne peut pas
imaginer une révolution de palais
s'il ya ya ya si vous voulez une
contradiction fondamentale entre
les propos de joe biden
c'est un boucher
on ne peut pas pour la sécurité du monde
avoir toujours poutine au pouvoir à
moscou et en même temps
une aide militaire un peu au compte
gouttes et des sanctions économiques qui
n'intègrent pas ceux qui feraient
vraiment très mal à la russie c'est à
dire l'arrêt des
[Musique]
du gard et des livraisons de l organe
pétrole parlons-en de cette sanction
économique on sent que les lignes
bougent sur la question militaire
puisque on apprend qu'un certain nombre
d'articles et plus lourdes alors armes
offensives ou pas mais en tout cas n'est
pas sont franchies et on sent que
certains pays le royaume-uni les
etats-unis la république tchèque les
turcs sont très allants sur la livraison
d'armes en revanche question sanctions
là il ya un gros débat les allemands
sont toujours opposés à cet embargo sur
le gaz russe les européens ont décidé
que de se passer pour l'instant du
charbon écoutez la réaction du député
européen belge différence stadt
savez pourquoi bonne stratégie ne marche
pas mais lorsque des plaques et de
sanction si cela ne marche pas avec la
zone de squats
il est temps de changer de stratégie
il faut organiser très vite un nouveau
conseil européen foudre full package un
paquet complet de sanctions pour faire
une vieille des terrains ce remake des
flux tout le reste ne fonctionnera pas
tout le reste ne fera que prolonger la
guerre tout le reste ne fera que
multiplier les décès dûs
un petit conseil à mes amis allemands
après les horreurs de la sorte de serre
mondiales il a émergé
je termine un berger allemand est forte
et profondément démocratique une très
forte et démocratique allemagne from
such john lee et d'unitel allemagne
j'attends un leadership donnant
l'exemple est neutre et non pas des
pieds conan doyon aujourd'hui
à cette vidéo elle est déjà été vue
plusieurs millions de fois et ce qui
l'est ce qui n'est pas lucide au fond
sur une forme de faiblesse de l'europe
canton sanction est ce que les européens
ont la main qui tremble face à poutine
kadiria en avant et après les images de
duch a c'est un tournant pour traiter un
tour est un tournant émotionnel il ya
une nouvelle bien nouveau l équilibre
émotionnel du monde même les chinois ont
du mal à ne pas être embarrassé
les indiens sont embarrassés donc il ya
un avant et un après et dans la presse
la politique
des européens devient presque
anachronique inadapté il conviendrait de
leur dire avec beaucoup de clarté que la
défense de la liberté a un prix que la
défense de la liberté un coup et je
dirais qu'à court terme nous allons
entrer vers le printemps nous y sommes
déjà ça rend pas vraiment compte vers
l'été on peut être un peu plus audacieux
en matière énergétique
dans la veille du mois de mai ça veut
dire être capable de faire un certain
nombre de sacrifices de privations oui
oui ça veut dire qu'on peut accepter de
dire que on aura moins chaud et qu'on
paiera un peu plus cher le pas sur la
question des armes on a l'impression que
effectivement les choses sont un petit
peu en train de bouger toute la question
est de savoir dans quelle mesure on a
une zone grise jusqu'où on peut penser
vous livrer des armes offensives on sait
que les britanniques les américains vont
beaucoup plus loin là encore que que les
européens comme on l'expliqué d'ailleurs
alors je croyais à yaya l'idée on ne
peut il faut tout faire pour que
l'ukraine ne perdent pas la guerre
mais rien faire pour rentrer nous dirait
qu aux belligérants guerre contre la
russie mais jusqu'à présent c'est
vraiment les américains et les
britanniques c'est ses traditions une
tradition quad eu le courage non je
crois au il ya
un engagement pour la liberté qui peut
très mal se terminer on l'a vu en irak
mais il ya effectivement alors quelle
est la différence entre une arme
défensive et une arme offensive on voit
que des tanks tchèques ont été livrés
déjà aux ukrainiens dans la bataille du
donbass qui va s'ouvrir dans la guerre
qui fait rage autour de marioupol
les ukrainiens ont besoin
d'artillerie lourde de tanks si on ne
leur livre pas tout en continuant à ne
pas interdire le ciel aux avions russes
il ya un contraste trop grand dernière
question dominique moïsi on est à la
veille d'une élection majeure pour notre
pays l'élection présidentielle on a vu
une forme de poutinisation des esprits
via un soft power qui s'est installée
juste que nos élites certains candidats
est-ce que vous pensez que ça y est on
est vacciné contre ça donc je dirais que
la démocratie se bat sur deux fronts
simultanés l'un est celui de la guerre
en ukraine l'autre est celui
des bureaux de vote en france et les
deux questions sont étroitement liés car
ce qui est en cause c'est vraiment
l'avenir de la démocratie en europe
merci beaucoup merci infiniment
dominique moïsi pour votre éclairage et
j'espère à bientôt sur sur ce plateau
c'est la fin de cette édition très bon
week end électoral et à semaine
prochaine
[Musique]